[APPLAUSE]
MARY CORCORAN: Well,
thank you very much.
I'm absolutely terrified.
That's the first
thing I have to say.
Because Caroline told me
this was a "perk" of the job.
And I teach at
third level, where
lectures would be considered
purgatory rather than perks,
where it's something that people
have to get through to try
and get to the other end.
So it's really exciting
for an academic
to be invited to come
and talk to Google people
because you are the unknowable--
the group of people
that we all hear about,
the millennials, et cetera.
But we know very
little about you.
So I hope that I'm
going to learn something
from you guys today.
And Caroline told me that the
theme Google has set this year
is fostering connection.
So what I've tried to
do is prepare a talk.
And I decided that I wouldn't
do the whole PowerPoint thing,
that I would actually
try and use some props.
So I'm going to be
channeling Mary Poppins.
And I don't have Mary
Poppins's carpetbag,
but I borrowed my son's
disgusting rucksack.
Which I realized is damp because
it was down at Electric Picnic,
so my props might be getting
a little bit shabby inside.
So I thought I would try
to use a few props to get
you thinking about
the sociological
meaning of connection.
And really, connection
is at the core
of what it is to be a human.
And that's what
sociologists look at.
We look at how
people are, how they
experience the world in
terms of their connectedness
with others.
And that's really important
because to connect with others
takes you out of
the privatized self.
And it creates, then, for us,
a public realm in which people
can interconnect.
And I suppose what
I'm trying to argue
is that there is a
continued significance
to that connectedness
in the digital age.
And I'm arguing, really,
in a sense, for a material
understanding of connectedness.
So what I'm going to talk to
you about is connectedness
or connectivity, not in
terms of the digital sphere,
which is where you guys all
work and excel, but in real,
grounded, rooted, co-present
kind of connectivity,
which has been central to the
work that I've been doing over
the last--
I don't even want to say it--
three decades as a sociologist.
So I'm not going to talk
about the Internet of Things.
I'm going to talk about
the sociology of things.
And if I have time, I'll try and
move on and talk a little bit
about disconnect because
there's another side
to this whole
connection narrative.
But we might leave that
aside and do questions
if we've run out of time.
OK, so prop number one, a
little drum roll, please?
[AUDIENCE DRUMMING ON DESKS]
[LAUGHS]
MARY CORCORAN: OK.
This is prop number one.
So you can have a look at that.
Tell me what I've
just thrown at you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
MARY CORCORAN: The
smell is unintentional.
AUDIENCE: It's a cushion.
MARY CORCORAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: With a
nice [INAUDIBLE]..
MARY CORCORAN: OK.
OK.
Do you want to throw it back?
Super.
OK, so it's a cushion.
It's in a sort of
a tweedy fabric,
and there's some
buttons on it, right?
SPEAKER: Let me screw
that mic on you, sorry.
MARY CORCORAN: Oh.
Apology.
SPEAKER: Cheers.
Thank you.
MARY CORCORAN: OK,
so I'm just going
to tell you a little back
story to this cushion.
There's a farmer,
a large farmer,
living in the
southeast of Ireland,
married, and produced
eight children--
seven girls and one boy.
In due course, the farm
and the farm house,
all of the wealth if you
like, created by that farmer,
was willed to the only son.
And the seven daughters
got their weddings,
which is kind of--
I'm not talking in
the 19th century.
I'm talking the
late 20th century.
So the seven daughters
were given their marriage.
It was, in effect, a dowry which
their father settled on them.
The man, this farmer, was
widowed quite early in life.
And then he was
predeceased by his son.
So in fact, his farm ended
up going out of the family.
And when he died, he
really left no belongings
except the clothes
that he retained.
Now, his seven daughters
had, throughout their lives,
and particularly in his later
life, taken care of him,
cooked for him, cleaned for
him, taken him out, and so on.
So after his death,
one of the sisters
discovered his old
suit in the wardrobe.
And she took it and she
made seven cushions out
of her dad's old suit.
You can see some of the buttons
and everything featured on it.
OK, so what am I
trying to say here?
Well, I think it tells us a
story about the Irish family.
And it is about connectedness
between members.
Before we think about
that, let's think
about the other
things it tell us.
First of all, it shows us how
patriarchal Irish families
traditionally have been.
The incredibly rigid gender
roles and gender norms
that underpinned the way in
which that family actually
functioned.
Now, today, we're moving towards
more egalitarian family forms.
But that notion that
there is a patriarch,
and that they
dictate who and how
the wealth that the family
has been created is dispersed,
is still very significant.
And that is often talked
about as a patrilineal line
of descent, that anything
that is useful or valuable
must go down through
the male line.
And particularly
in Ireland, we have
a history of strong
property lot rights
and a form of
inheritance which focused
very much on a son,
a single son, really,
disinheriting the
rest of the family.
And that relates right
back to the famine.
So what we see there is
how a kind of history
imprints itself on the social
practice of modern day.
But obviously, also, this
man was a paterfamilias.
He was the head of the family.
He was loved and respected and
remembered after he is gone.
And that brings me to his death.
I mean, death, in Ireland,
is a particular kind
of way of recreating
connections.
Death in Ireland is
very ritualistic.
Particularly if you're a
member of the Catholic church,
there are a whole series
of rituals that you
go through when somebody dies--
from removal, to
Mass, to Month's Mind,
to annual graveyard, masses,
to creating memorial cards,
and so on.
And they're the
ways, really, that we
try to keep that deceased
person somehow alive,
somehow connected to
the continuing reality.
And I just like this, because
I think the cushion represents
an innovative way of maintaining
some sense of connectedness,
of belonging to someone
who is deceased,
and keeping the memory alive
in a kind of really practical,
material culture way.
It's not a nap.
It's a cushion.
But every time somebody sits
on that cushion or farts
on that cushion,
they might think
about the dad or the grandfather
who once actually inhabited
the suit.
OK, are you ready
for the next prop?
OK.
[RATTLING BAG]
I'm not going to
throw this one out
in case somebody doesn't
throw it back to me.
OK, so my second prop is
a packet of Tayto Crisps.
Tayto Crisps are the number
one crisps in the Irish market,
and they are beloved of
Irish people worldwide.
Mr. Tayto, as you
can see, is about
as far removed from Kim
Kardashian as you can imagine.
But he holds a very dear
place in Irish hearts.
And what's interesting
about Tayto is, as a brand,
it doesn't travel.
It has never been able to
make it into any other market,
except amongst the Irish.
Now back in the 1980s, I
undertook a PhD in sociology
in New York City.
And I hadn't chosen a
topic for my thesis.
But while I was there,
I was working one summer
in a restaurant downtown.
And I just became aware of this
large number of Irish people
who were running
around, waitering
and waitressing in
these restaurants,
and I became one of them.
And I discovered that they
were all then going back home
in the evenings to little
ethnic enclaves in Queens
and in the Bronx.
And these, now, were a group of
people who were undocumented.
They were there without papers,
without social security cards,
working, if you like,
in the informal economy.
But of course-- and so
it presented itself to me
as a topic to investigate.
So I ended up doing my doctorate
on the undocumented Irish
in New York.
And of course, one of
the things that happens,
if you're an nondocumented
immigrant in particular,
is that you are really very much
confined to an ethnic enclave.
Your connections cannot
be really outside of that,
because you have this sort of
legal status issue that acts
as a barrier against
any kind of interaction.
So with the Irish in
New York in the 1980s,
they were intensely
ethnicized, if you like.
They were really
dependent on power brokers
in the Irish American
community to give them jobs.
They were dependent
on landlords who were
willing to accept cash in hand.
And of course, they all
congregated together
in the pubs in the
Bronx and in Queens.
And what did they do?
They swilled lots of beer, and
they consumed boxfuls of Tayto.
And the Tayto had to be
imported from Ireland, as did--
and this, now, is going back
in the '80s, it's very much
pre-internet--
Gaelic games-- major effort
to get them onto television
screens that could be shown
in pubs so that people
could connect in with them.
People used to telephone home,
like, from a dial up phone,
to put money on horse
races back in Ireland,
and then phone a few hours later
to see if their horse came in.
So the point really is that,
even though those undocumented
Irish in the '80s, they were
thousands of miles from home,
not really able to integrate in
mainstream American culture--
at least there were some
constraints on that--
they nevertheless, maintained a
very strong high identification
with their sense of
Irishness, but also
with their sense of home.
And that, I think, can
happen in multiple ways.
I mean, nowadays we talk
about Skype and Facebook
and all of these
things connect people
across space and across time.
But I think Tayto Crisps have
a role to play here as well.
Because they are
something from home.
They're quintessentially Irish.
They've got this absolutely
horrific brand, Mr. Tayto,
who somehow has
managed to survive
in a world of
aesthetic perfection.
And it links us back, right?
It links us back.
And it is easily transportable
and provides a particular kind
of sensory experience.
I'm sure most of
you in this room
have that lovely pleasure
of opening a bag of crisps
and getting your
first munch of it.
And I think that that really
represents a symbolic linking
back to home.
But it also--
I mentioned earlier,
that imprint of history--
it does relate
back to the potato.
The potato in Irish, culture
going right back to the famine,
that there's something about
spuds that Irish people love.
We just can't go
for more than three
or four days without
having a spud.
And Tayto Crisps are
quite a good substitute.
In fact, I was at my
brother-in-law's 50th birthday
party in Alexandria,
Virginia last weekend.
And one of the things
that was brought over,
apart from the Barry's tea, was
a large box of Tayto Crisps.
So it's not just
technology that links
people across space and time.
I think it's also
sensory experiences,
material artifacts,
if you like, that
can create that same
kind of connectedness.
OK.
How am I doing for time?
Yeah?
Not too bad.
OK, so prop number three--
da, da, da, da--
I can see you're all just
getting carried away with this.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Exhibit 3, everybody
recognize what we've got here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARY CORCORAN: Yeah?
Football jersey, right?
Dublin-- the best
team at the moment--
the winners.
OK, so we put our
football jersey up there.
OK.
So sport-- all forms
of sport really
develop a following that is
predicated on identification,
connection to
something or someone.
So it can be a connection
to an individual
like the way in which
a lot of Irish people
like Conor McGregor.
Or it can be a
connection to a team,
like the Dublin
footballers, or the Kilkenny
hurlers, or the New
England Patriots,
or whatever the case may be.
There goes our
construction outside.
OK.
And what I was arguing, what
sociologists would argue,
is that people turn to sport
and other experiences like music
for an experience of
what Emile Durkheim, back
in the 19th century, called
collective effervescence.
I think it's a fabulous term.
Durkheim was writing
about religion.
He was trying to
understand why people
had created religion,
why people created a god
and focus on that.
And Durkheim argued
that what we do, really,
in creating religion
is that we want
to celebrate society,
i.e., the social connection
between each other.
But it's difficult to do that
in the everyday profane, sort
of lived life.
So what people did was to
create a kind of godlike figure
and to sort of transfer
onto the god figure
that sense of identity,
of connectedness.
So in other words, that god
is simply reflecting back
to us, ourselves, society.
Now, religion, I
mean, obviously,
that's a huge area to get into.
In some parts of the world,
religious experience,
religious effervescence
has intensified.
But in the Western world, it
has really been declining.
And what sociologists
have noticed
is that things like sports
and music, in a way,
have become a kind of
replacement or substitute
for religion.
So if we think about that, if we
think about people heading off
to the All-Ireland
final, Dublin and Mayo,
you can actually
see the same sort
of processes going on that
would have traditionally gone
on around a religious event or
a religious kind of experience.
So usually there's a kind
of a build up, right?
People are getting ready.
I remember when I was a
kid, for Mass on Sunday,
my dad would just take out
six children, Catholic family,
take out all the
shoes and polish them
all on a Saturday night for
us to go to Mass on Sunday.
That was a build up.
It was saying something
special is going to happen.
Same-- people here will start
listening to commentary,
checking stuff out,
making sure they
have the latest, up-to-date
version of their jersey, and so
on.
Sports events, like
religious events,
also really rely on
group interaction,
on people coming together, and
focusing on sacred symbols.
Within the church, it's
all about the altar, what
the priest is doing, and so on.
On the field, it's
about the champs,
waving the scarves
at the right time,
singing, screaming,
profanities at the ref when
they are required So
all of that, in a way,
is about strengthening shared
beliefs, values, aspirations,
and emotion.
So whether you're doing
it at Mass on Sunday,
whether you're in Croke
Park, whether you're down
at Electric Picnic,
you're engaging
in a process of experiencing
what Durkheim called
collective effervescence.
And I think that is a really
important way in which we
sort of materially and
physically connect with others.
So putting on that jersey
immediately puts you
into a place where you're
playing a particular role.
You're making a statement about
a particular set of values
and belongings that you embody.
So that's really, if you like,
the symbolic value of sport.
But there's also a very powerful
instrumental or functional
value to sport.
And particularly-- and
I'm speaking really
from the Irish context
here, and from research
that I have done,
but particularly
in terms of inculcating a sense
of belonging in communities.
Now a few years
ago, I got to debate
with Robert Putnam,
a very famous Harvard
political scientist, who wrote
a book called "Bowling Alone."
And it was about the decline
of community in America.
And he used that metaphor, that
nobody went bowling in groups
anymore in America.
And that this was
really, if you like,
easing into the body politic.
And I remember when I
was debating with him,
I had one great
argument as my retort.
The Gaelic Athletic
Association, the GAA,
which was founded in Ireland in
the 1880s as part of Ireland's
attempt to self-determine
as a separate country,
with separate value system,
culture, practices, et cetera,
to Britain.
The GAA is a nationally
organized, voluntary
organization.
Voluntary-- so
people are not paid.
And it operates
in the 32 counties
of the Republic of Ireland.
It operates in every tiny
locality throughout Ireland.
A few years ago myself
and some colleagues
did a-- now, we know that it's
very powerful in rural Ireland.
And apart from
Dublin, mainly it has
been rural teams
that have really
been the top performers,
if you like, historically.
But Dublin has grown.
And Dublin, I think, anyone
here who is a betting person,
will surely think
that Dublin are going
to absolutely destroy Mayo.
I'm sorry for
Mayo, the underdog,
but I think Dublin
are going to win.
Well, how is it so
strong in Dublin?
Dublin is a metropolitan area.
Well, we did some research
on new suburban communities
in and around the
hinterland of Dublin.
And one of the things
that we were trying to do
was to investigate, are the
suburbs, the new suburban areas
of Dublin, the areas
that have grown 5,
10, 15 miles from the city
center, are they really
the social deserts
that we hear about?
Because suburbs get
a terrible press.
They get a terrible
press from the movies,
in literature,
where they're always
seen as the places that suck
you dry and destroy your soul
and turn you into a broken
down alcoholic or a manic sort
of Annette Bening in
"American Beauty."
So the suburb, then--
some we would say-- and
particularly, "The Irish Times"
had taken an absolute
dislike and thought everyone
should be living in high
rise in the city center.
Anyone who's in the burbs--
social death.
So we went and we investigated
four of these suburbs.
And we found,
actually, they're not.
They're places that
people really like to live
and that most people
choose to live in.
And we found, really, there
are very strong levels
of identification with place.
And that identification with
place is connected to a village
being there, a little bit of
history, a bit of tradition,
a bit of heritage.
Something like that made
a big difference to people
because it gave them a sense
of connection to the place.
It was a place that
you could call.
For example, in Ratoath
in County Meath,
people were very
aware that there
was a history of horse
racing in the area
and that it was a very
pastoral environment.
And that was really important
to their self-identification
as suburbanites.
We also found that people
had a lot of social supports
in terms of five or six people
that they could call upon
to mind a child, to borrow
a little bit of money,
to share a problem with
on an ongoing basis, which
is actually
internationally quite high,
having five to six people
in your close network.
And the third thing was we found
a lot of social participation.
But the main factor of social
participation was the GAA.
So people of all
ages were involved.
It was a kind of a hub
that got children--
because it really mentors
children from a young age,
it brings those parents into
these circuits of sociability
that then operate.
And of course, that doesn't
just operate in suburban Dublin,
it operates in the
Irish diaspora,
beyond Ireland, where we have
GAA clubs in places like Dubai.
So it's actually creating a
kind of a social capital that
forms a social glue
for people, that
keeps a community connected.
And I what's particularly
interesting about the GAA
is that it's actually
cross-generational.
So you can get involved in it
as a 5-year-old, 10, 15, 20.
You can stay as a
mentor, as a trainer.
You can actually join
your local GAA club
as an aging person like myself--
the over 55's-- and you can get
a cheaper drink in the club.
[LAUGHTER]
And that, in itself, is a bonus.
We found very high
membership rates
in Leixlip, County Kildare,
mainly because of the cheaper
drink in the bar.
But the point, really, is
a little bit more serious
than that.
But there are certain
kinds of social processes.
And I think the GAA is
very particular to Ireland,
that can create and foster
this sort of connection.
OK, so fourth-- [LAUGHS]
[AUDIENCE DRUMMING ON DESKS]
Like, I'm an academic,
so I'm really
supposed to have something
to do with books.
So I brought a book
I'll just pass around.
Copy-- you can just
pass it around.
So this is a little project
I wanted to tell you about.
Because, again, I
think it's an example
of material culture being
able to express something,
to give a message, to give voice
to an experience that otherwise
isn't often heard.
So there's this wonderful
artist called Mary Burke, who
is Dublin-based, but
she's spent all her life
painting suburban portraits,
mainly suburban portraits
in middle-class County Dublin.
So she got involved
in West Tallaght.
West Tallaght is one of the most
disadvantaged areas in Ireland.
When you talk to the
people there, as I did,
they often use terms,
like, it's like Beirut.
It's Apache land up here.
So they really have
internalized this sense
that they're off the edge, that
they're a kind of a war zone,
if you like, beyond the norm.
Now, what we did was Mary Burke,
the artist, Tallaght Community
Arts, and myself got together.
And 10 families were selected
to have a portrait painted
of their house.
Now, these are mostly
social housing units,
so they're not salubrious
South County Dublin dwellings.
They're pretty ordinary
social housing.
So what Mary did was to
photograph each house,
and then to paint an individual
portrait of each one.
And then I interviewed all of
the families involved, mainly,
really, to find out from them,
their understanding of home,
what that the house
meant to them, and so on.
And then what we did
was to produce it
as a book, which shows the
process of the portraits being
painted, and then has
an essay by myself which
tries to interpret what
home means to the people who
were involved.
Now, I think what's
interesting about this
is that when we talk about
disadvantaged people, people
in Tallaght West,
they're often focused on,
from a deficit model.
They're people that need things.
They're people
that have problems.
They're people that
can't manage their lives.
They're dysfunctional,
they're chaotic, et cetera.
But by doing this
project, we were
able to provide a much
more positive resource
model of the people.
Because what we did
was really to focus
on their energy, their
imagination in how they dwell,
how they live
within their homes.
And what we found is that,
much like everybody else,
home means certain things
to people in Tallaght West.
They love it as a
physical structure.
They talked about the
sturdiness of the house.
They loved it as a
territory, a place
where they could set markers.
And that's really important in a
place like Tallaght West, where
you don't have control over
the external environment, where
there might be a bit of
anti-social behavior going on
outside your front door.
So it becomes really
important to know
that you can close
the door on that,
that you can draw
your net curtains.
And you'll see, if you
flick through the book,
that everybody has net curtains.
So they can look out,
but people can't look in.
And home is a place of
self-expression and identity,
right?
Of course, the difference
is that for people
in Tallaght West, a lot of
the time they're dreaming.
So I interview them--
say, I'd love to do this.
I'm going to try and paint this.
At some point, I
would like to do--
if you're middle class,
if you have resources,
you can actually
make the changes.
They want to change.
They want to inscribe their
own kind of identity on it,
but it often remains
kind of aspirational.
And of course, a lot of
the decor in these homes
are family portraits, family
portraits all over the walls,
another way of connecting
in with family.
And homes also operated for them
as a social and cultural unit.
If you have a home, your family
can come in and out of it.
I am really stressing
this because we're
living in a moment
in Ireland where
there's a massive problem
with homelessness.
And when you think about how
the so-called disadvantaged
in this book talk about
how significant home is,
it actually makes it
all the more stark
what people who are
homeless are missing.
So having a home means that
people come in and out.
Your parents come by.
Your father comes
down to do the garden.
Your children are in and out.
And pets-- that was the
biggest revelation for me
was the amount of
people who absolutely
adore having dogs,
cats, lizards, goldfish,
et cetera, in their home.
And that those pets
themselves take
on a personality of their own.
OK.
So why am I stressing this?
Because I think in the
production of these set
of portraits-- by the way,
the portraits were exhibited
in Tallaght and in a few
more places around Dublin--
but amazingly, each
portrait was, then,
presented to the family
whose home had been painted,
which is a total inversion of
the normal situation, where
art that is publicly
on display usually
goes into private collections.
In this case, the art that
was produced, if you like,
went back to the people
whose homes had been painted.
And it wasn't, if you
like, commercialized
in the normal way.
In fact, it was just a
temporary public good.
People could see
it, but it wasn't
something that was out
there in the public domain.
So I think what is most
significant about the book is
that it tries to reframe our
understandings of how people
live in places that are a
little bit off the grid,
off the beaten track.
And it challenges some
of the stereotypes
and some of the
assumptions that we make
about people who live there.
OK.
So moving on, fifth
and final prop--
if it hasn't become--
yeah.
Is my basil plant, OK?
It's a nice little
bit of greenery.
Actually, this is becoming quite
a nice little tableau here.
OK.
When is a plant
not just a plant?
Well, when it becomes a
basis for social belonging
and when it starts to produce
social and civic dividends
for the community.
So one of the things I've been
doing over the last few years
is working with a
group of Europeans
across 23 countries in Europe,
looking at urban agriculture.
Because what we've noted
is that, particularly
since the downturn,
the crisis of 2008,
there's been a massive
resurgence in urban agriculture
across Europe.
And I use that term
extremely widely, because it
can be anything from growing
fruit and veg in a window box
to actually setting up an
urban farm, a proper, sort
of commercialized
urban farm, where
you're trying to produce
and supply a local market.
So in a way, if you like, one
of the unintended consequences
of austerity was a new interest
or a renewal of interest,
I should say, in issues
to do with food--
food provenance, food
security, self-efficacy--
being capable or able or
knowing where something grows,
how it grows, and how
to harvest and tend it.
And food justice-- the
idea that all of us,
really, ought to
be able to access
good quality, high quality
food that is locally available.
So as I said, with
the European project,
we looked at examples
right across Europe,
and we looked at different
levels of urban agriculture.
And what, really, we found right
across the way is that these
are fantastic facilities,
based in cities,
in and around peri-urban area
that are accessible to people--
and again, it's
regardless of age--
that can be used by unemployed
people, by homeless people,
by people with special needs,
people with disabilities
and that there is huge kind
of social benefits to getting
your hands dirty with soil,
cultivating, and seeing, if you
like, the fruit of your labor.
So it probably is the opposite
of digital production,
in that, you actually
get a sort of a product
after starting with a seed and
doing lots of things to it,
right, in the process.
Now I was particularly
interested in this
because we did a
little bit of research
which looked at urban allotments
in Dublin and also in Belfast.
And as you know, Belfast is
a very, very segregated city.
So anyone who's
been to Belfast will
know that, territorially, it
is very divided along sort
of ethnonational lines.
So you know when you're
entering a nationalist area,
because there'll be murals.
The sidewalks will be painted
green, white, and orange,
or red, white, and blue.
So there's constant
signifiers in the public space
of the city telling
you this is Catholic,
and this is Protestant.
And of course, in the era of the
peace process, lots of attempts
are being made to bring the two
communities together, right?
And lots of resources
have gone into that.
But what we found was that--
and it's a slightly
overlooked space--
that, if we look at the
kind of politics of place
around urban
agriculture in Belfast,
you find something
very interesting--
that the agricultural
plots that people utilize
are actually a place where
ethnoreligious differences are
parked at the gate.
So the whole focus of coming
into an allotment site,
and taking out your tools, and
doing your bit of gardening,
and opening your flask,
having a cup of tea,
is all about cultivation.
People don't talk
about politics.
They don't ask each other
about their background.
It's a public space where
there is a single focus,
and you do not have to
become intimate with others
or know anything.
So we found that a lot
of the time, people
only know people by
their first name.
But politics is
parked at the gate.
And we found that
particularly interesting,
that something as basic
as just growing vegetables
could, if you like,
have a role in creating
a more equitable version
of the contemporary city,
particularly when we
think about a city
where there are
serious problems.
OK.
So I've just a few
more minutes left.
So I'll just try and pull some
of that together a little more.
So when I was thinking
about this talk,
and about focusing on
connections and connectedness,
I also started to think,
OK, I can talk a little bit
about some research I've done.
I can show how we are connected.
But there is also a
flip side to that,
which is disconnection
and disconnectedness.
And one of the
things that I think
has gone through each
of these five examples,
which is somewhat serendipitous
because I kind of just
pulled them together
rather eclectically,
is the whole issue
of social class.
And social class is interesting
because social class does
reinforce connection
within class,
but it also creates
division between classes.
And I mean, that's
not a new insight.
That's exactly what Marx was
saying in the 19th century,
and what Max Weber also said.
And indeed, Marx and
Weber both argued
that social class is
based around one group
having something,
one not having it.
Weber was a little bit more-- he
talks about things like status
and access to power as well.
But more recently, a British
sociologist, Mike Savage,
did this really cool thing at
the great BBC class survey.
It was a piece of
academic research,
but it was also done through
a kind of an outreach
through the BBC to the
British public where
they tried to kind of unpick
a little bit what does class
mean in the contemporary world.
And he borrowed from
Pierre Bourdieu,
the French sociologist,
to argue that, when
we think about
class now, we have
to think about it as economic
capital, which means money,
and wealth, and land.
We have to think about it
as cultural capital, which
means being able to appreciate
and engage with cultural goods
like being able to go to
festivals, listen to music,
appreciate art, play
sports, use the gym,
and so on, and also having
educational credentials,
which, of course,
you all have tons of.
So cultural capital is
really important, probably,
I think increasingly, the
most important capital.
And thirdly, there's
the social capital,
which is our contacts
and connectedness that
allow people to create a social
network around themselves which
they can then draw upon.
OK.
So just thinking back, then, on
what I've been saying and using
my props from the perspective
of social class, in Ireland,
land has always
been and continues
to be a hugely powerful
resource in our society.
So Marx and Weber both talked
about the propertied class
and the property-less class.
And amazingly, that is the
world that we live in today.
We live in a world where people
either are homed, or have
homes, or access to homes,
or people are homeless.
And that sort of really
strong commitment to property
and the right to
property is strongly
enshrined in our constitution.
It cannot be removed.
And interestingly, Iceland
underwent a, sort of,
a crowdfunded constitutional
review a couple of years
ago, where it sort of
was a crowd-based attempt
to rewrite the
Icelandic constitution.
They couldn't get any
change on the right
to property in
that constitution.
So in Ireland, I think, that
has been a huge obstacle
to creating a basis for greater
cohesion in our society.
So we go back to our farmer.
Seven daughters, one son,
but that precious boy
must get that farm so as not
to lose that family resource,
that it must be retained.
So that sort of notion
of land and property
and how you hang on to what
you have is really significant.
And I spoke about the Tayto,
as the Tayto-loving Irish
immigrants.
But that didn't really
encompass all of the immigrants.
Because we can't assume
homogeneity amongst immigrants
living in any society.
There are very clear
class differentials
in terms of people's access
to economic, cultural,
and social capital.
So when I did it-- because I did
a lot of research on the Irish
abroad, and then I did
research on returners,
people who came back.
And I came up with a
kind of a typology.
I don't actually-- I
only made 15 copies.
I was very pessimistic about
how many people would show up.
So you can just
have a look at it,
or pass it on to somebody else.
So what I was trying to
do there was to show that
if you're thinking about who
a migrant-- and some of you,
I'm sure, are immigrants
in this room--
you can actually
think about where do I
fit on a migration typology?
So this is the typology I
generated to try and capture
that notion that, when
we're in the world,
we all have access to these
different kind of resources.
So I've described three
different types of emigrant.
And this is all based on
research on Irish people.
But I think some of
it actually would
work for Polish and Lithuanian
and Romanian as well.
So the reserve
army immigrants are
the ones that Marx
talked about, the people
who basically are the sand
crew lot, the people who
have little skill,
little opportunity,
and will go anywhere for work.
The global adventurers
are the kind
of flexible, mobile,
contingent people--
gap years, two-year
visa in Canada,
want to spend a bit of time
out of my home country.
And the cosmopolites
are the elites--
the international, circulating,
transnational people who
go where people
beg them to go, who
are at the very, very
top of their profession,
and essentially spend
50% of their lives
on a jet flying
around the world.
So then, what I'm
suggesting is that we
can understand their
experiences in terms
of the different opportunity
structures they face,
different decision makings
they are able to make,
their primary goals, which are
all different, their persona.
So my argument is that the
Irish I met in New York
were the undocumented.
They didn't have
many rights, legally.
That forced them into a strong,
kind of ethnic orientation,
and so they end up being
Tayto Crisp eaters.
Whereas, people who go to
work in one of the big four
financial firms in
New York are going
to be sipping
Manhattans in Manhattan.
They're not going to be
out in Queens eating Tayto.
And you can see
at the end, I just
said, the overall status
position for reserve army
people-- it's precarious.
And there's a lot of
research in sociology
now going on about the
precarious workplace, which
is actually growing.
The global adventurers
are the hipsters.
And maybe there's a lot
of hipsters in this room.
The cosmopolites are
the citizen-like people.
These are the people that won't
be impacted by Brexit, that
are just above all of that,
that just are extremely
well-secured in their position.
OK.
I'm going to finish
up in just a second.
OK.
So I wanted to make that point
about class and the migration
issue.
I talked about the suburbs
as great places to live,
and people really sort of
connecting with each other
through things like the GAA.
But I also would
like you to remember
that Dublin is one
of the most spatially
and socially segregated
cities in Europe.
We don't mix our social classes,
and we don't mix our housing
types in Ireland.
Private home ownership
is glorified.
Anybody else who doesn't
own their own home
is somehow a failure, hasn't
got on the property ladder,
didn't do it right.
People in Ireland do live in
either affluence or in poverty
and Tallaght West is
one example of that.
Even with sport--
I emphasized the whole GAA
thing, the community thing--
but we know that sport
itself is class stratified.
And that certain
sports, rugby, are
associated with a particular
form of social class
reproduction through
private school education,
through having the right kind
of social networks, and so on.
Whereas other sports like
boxing and martial arts,
like Conor McGregor,
traditionally
are really based in a
working-class male culture.
The last example I talked
about were the allotments
and the urban agriculture.
And to me, they do
have some potential
around this social integration.
Because on allotments, as I
already mentioned in relation
to Northern Ireland,
people meet as strangers,
and they can remain so.
There's no obligation
to get to know people,
to hang out with
them, to have anything
to do with them beyond
the on-site cultivation
or activity.
So they fulfill a
very important role
associated with urban
public life, which
Richard Sennett has written
really eloquently about.
That, we all need spaces that
are relatively open to all,
no cost of entry, where people
can congregate, communicate,
encounter each other
in fleeting exchanges,
and where there's just a
level of confidence and trust
that makes it work, but
doesn't mean that we ever
have to become anything but
sort of passing strangers
to each other.
And those spaces are important.
Because they do generate a
sense of subjective competence,
but also a sense of
collective belonging,
that we are connected to others.
So I think they form part
of a public realm which
offers the potential
for intersection
points between different
class groupings.
And I've used allotments
as an example of that,
and the allotments that
we've looked at in Dublin
definitely have lots of
eviden-- one of the things
that people described
the allotments
as is social levelers.
Everybody's got their boots on.
It doesn't matter who you
are, or where you come from,
we're all doing the same thing.
If you go to cycle one
of the fabulous greenways
around Ireland now, Waterford
or Westport, again, they're
spaces of social intersection--
all kinds of people on them,
all kinds of bicycling, all
kinds of levels of fitness,
and they all mix together.
If you go for a swim in
the Forty Foot, which
I do frequently, or in Seapoint,
you will meet all of human life
there, I guarantee you.
So really, my final point is
to make an argument that we
believe in connection, that
we believe in connection
as something which
is about co-presence,
and that these kind of public
realm spaces that are open,
that are social-leveling
spaces, are very distinct from
privatized, policed spaces--
spaces like shopping malls,
like gated communities, or even
social media to some extent,
which is highly individualized
and where everyone is
heavily surveilled.
So I'm arguing for the
promotion, creation,
and inhabiting the
public realm because I
think that is a way of pushing
back against the forces that
would divide us--
and we know what
those forces are--
and the forces that would
demonize the other in society.
Thanks very much
for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]